Emotions can help us in the process of our ability to remember through both
genetic processes, as well as biochemical processes. In fact, when we
experience an emotional event, it can actually cause a change in our genetics.
Such that they build proteins and strengthen synaptic connections between
neurons. We discuss this in detail in Lesson 3. So proteins stimulate the
formation of new synapses and even new neurons. This results in our ability to
make memories last for longer periods of time. On the biochemical side, the
neurotransmitter, norepinephirine is important for the formation of memories.
Because it strengthens the synaptic connection between neurons. Remember that
neuroplasticity is necessary for making the connection between synapses
stronger, and thus make an event more memorable. One other variable that
affects our memory is sleep. Sleep can help us consolidate our memories.
Remember, however, from information that we previously discussed in this
lesson, that our memories are not always perfectly correct. We know that
emotions can actually distort memories. In fact, it appears that emotional
memories tend to be less accurate in details than nonemotional memories.